الحرب في اوكرانيا بالنسبه للكثيرين في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو شيء يحدث بعيدا جدا
يرونه فقط على الشاشات حتى بدات الهجمات
الاوكرانيه في العمق الروسي هجمات اخرجت
بوتين ليتهم بمحاوله ترويع المواطنين
الروس هو تغيرا في الحرب التي تشهد تغيرات
كل فتره لكن من ثوابتها الاجهزه السريه
التابعه او موسكو تخوض معارك معلومات
واستخبارات اثارها انعكست على الميدان
تاريخ مشترك جمع جهاز الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ونظيره الروسي لكن وبعد تفكك
الاتحاد السوفيتي اختار كل منهما طريقا
منفص لا بعد ان بات الجهاز الاوكراني
هيكلا سوفيتيا بخصائص غربيه
[موسيقى]
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه على عكس نظيرتها
الروسيه تحولت الى جهاز صغير متحرر وعلى
عكس سلسله الاسلوب السوفيتي الذي عانى
كثيرا من البيروقراطيه زيلينسكي
عينو رئيسا للجهاز الامني عام 2020
بودانوب شاب لم يتدرج في الجيش لكنه يمتلك
تجربه طويله
فيلنسكي منح بودانوب ورقه بيضاء من اجل
نقل الحرب داخل روسيا بكل الوسائل والهدف
اجعل الروس يشعرون بالحرب مهمته بودنوب
الاولى كانت تطهير الادارات الاوكرانيه من
عملاء روسيا مهمه شاقه بالطبع لكنها نجحت
لاعتمادها على معلومات غربيه في اعتقال
800 عميلا روسي منذ بدايه الحرب فيكتور
ميدفيتشوك واحد من الثماني مئه من اهم
رجال روسيا
في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
صفقه تبادل
شوك عفوا مع روسيا مقابله 200 جندي شكلت
اسسا دعائيه لصالح رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه بودانو لكن رغم ذلك هناك ازمات
يعنيها الجهاز 60 عميلا للاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه انشقوا واختاروا البقاء
والتعاون مع موسكو في المناطق التي سيطرت
عليها ربما لانهم كانوا منذ البدايه عملاء
لروسيا احتمال اخر هو ان روسيا اقنعتهم
بالانضمام اليها ليتحصلوا بعدها على مناصب
جيده في الادارات الجديده
مسؤولون كبار في الاداره يشتبه في علاقتهم
مع روسيا سهلوا عمليه دخول الجيش الروسي
لخرسون وايضا الى مقاطعه في بدايه الحرب
الا ان الاخطر هم من ينتمون للاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه
اعتقلت كياب ضابط استخبارات سابقيه يبلغ
من العمر 77 عاما بعد تقديمه لمقر اقامه
الجيش الاوكراني في الفيب معلوماته تسببت
في تلقي كيب اكبر ضربه في غرب البلاد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات